[Música]
islandia es el país más aislado del
mundo
hablamos de una isla en mitad del océano
atlántico que está poblada por poco más
de 350.000 habitantes es decir que
cualquier barrio de nueva york- tiene
más población la capital más cercana a
islandia es oslo en noruega y está a
2.500 km de distancia sin embargo
islandia es uno de los países más ricos
del planeta y podría convertirse en la
capital internacional de una industria
muy pero que muy moderna hablamos de las
cripto divisas
islandia el paraíso para los mineros de
cripto monedas y os preguntaréis pero
cómo es posible que un país tan remoto
pueda ser tan importante para una
industria como la de las cripto divisas
pues en este vídeo os lo vamos a contar
[Aplausos]
[Música]
islandia es uno de los países más
peculiares del mundo un lugar donde más
de la mitad de sus habitantes cree
todavía en la existencia de los elfos
sin embargo también se trata de una de
las economías más avanzadas y modernas
de todo el planeta tierra
da igual la métrica que miréis islandia
es uno de estos países que siempre está
entre los lugares mejor ubicados los
islandeses son más ricos que los
estadounidenses o los daneses además son
el octavo país más igualitario del mundo
y también son el líder indiscutible en
energías renovables básicamente son el
único país de la tierra que puede
presumir de que el cien por cien de su
energía es completamente verde y ya sé
lo que estaréis pensando muchos islandia
pero no se trata del país que más sufrió
la gran crisis financiera de 2008 exacto
cuando pensamos en islandia pensamos en
un país que se declaró en bancarrota
tras la crisis financiera sin embargo en
sólo 13 años han recuperado todo lo que
perdieron y diréis pero como lo han
conseguido esto es tema para otro vídeo
que sacaremos dentro de muy poco aquí en
visual político pero podemos resumirlo
en tres palabras turismo recursos
naturales y cripto divisa
atentos
13 de febrero de 2018 como islandia se
convirtió en el paraíso de los mineros
de bitcoin es casi imposible hacer un
cálculo exacto de cuánto bitcoin o
cuántas cripto divisas se minan desde
islandia hoy en día pero se calcula que
esta industria supone casi el 1 por
ciento de todo el pib del país según
algunas estimaciones islandia mina el 8
por ciento de todo el bitcoin que se
utiliza hoy en día y repito todo esto
son estimaciones porque realmente nadie
tiene información exacta lo que sí
podemos decir es que islandia es cada
vez más importante dentro del mundo
cripto y tiene una serie de ventajas que
le pueden convertir atentos en el hong
kong de la script o divisas la pregunta
es hasta qué punto es bueno que un país
entero depende del bitcoin kim pacto
teológico puede tener el bitcoin en
islandia y cuáles son todas esas
ventajas que tienen los mineros de
bitcoin en este país hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia un
mercado muy caliente para el planeta
[Música]
seguramente muchos hayáis oído que los
mineros de bitcoins generan montones de
emisiones de co2 verdad y algunos se
preguntarán pero porque qué tiene que
ver el bit coin con la contaminación y
qué es exactamente un minero de bitcoin
seguro que muchos ya lo sabéis pero
otros seguramente no tengáis tan claro
así que antes de seguir vamos a hacer un
breve resumen vamos a imaginar que yo le
envío 100 euros a un amigo alguien se
tiene que encargar de verificar esa
transacción es decir asegurarse de que
en mi cuenta de banco tengo 100 euros
menos y en la de mi amigo hay 100 euros
más quién se encarga de verificar esta
transacción pues bien en el sistema
financiero actual lo hacen los bancos
sin embargo los bancos no existen en el
mundo cripto entonces quién verifica
todas estas transacciones pues bien aquí
es donde entra en escena la figura del
dinero
[Música]
no hablamos de ese tipo de minero en
realidad nos referimos a este minero
veréis la característica principal de la
escrito divisas es que todos los
usuarios guardan una copia del mismo
libro de cuentas en ese libro de cuentas
se guardan todas las transacciones que
se han hecho en esta cripto divisa a lo
largo de la historia es decir que
técnicamente cualquier usuario de
bitcoin o de f1 de cualquier otra cripto
divisa podría ser un dinero entonces
como se elige el que se encarga de
verificar esa transacción pues podríamos
decir que se hace un concurso tal cual
como lo es el sistema de bitcoin crea
una ecuación muy complicada la llamada
prueba de trabajo y el primer usuario en
resolverla es el encargado de verificar
esa transacción y diréis que recibe a
cambio pues dos cosas por un lado al
minero se le paga una comisión por la
transacción por el otro se le paga con
bitcoins de nueva creación como sabéis
la idea de bitcoin es que solo se van a
crear 21 millones de bitcoin en el mundo
pues bien esos bitcoins se van creando a
medida que se paga a los mineros y por
eso se les llama mineros y sí ya lo sé
esta es una explicación muy simple y nos
hemos dejado muchísimas cosas en el
tintero pero esto es
imprescindible que necesitáis para poder
entender la historia que os vamos a
contar a continuación porque como os
podéis imaginar esta ecuación no se
resuelve de forma manual es decir que no
os imagináis a una chica muy lista
tratando de resolver una ecuación con
papel y boli en realidad hablamos de
problemas que se resuelven con
ordenadores cuanto más potente sea el
ordenador más rápido podrán resolverla
como os podéis imaginar esto ha generado
una carrera endiablada por ver quién
tiene el ordenador más potente para que
os hagáis una idea esto es un centro de
minado de bitcoin hoy en día
lo que estáis viendo en pantalla son
cientos de procesadores y tarjetas
gráficas puestas juntas en una nave para
crear un súper ordenador súper
ordenadores que pueden ser hasta 800
veces más rápido que un ordenador normal
y aquí es donde llega el problema
ecológico porque como os podéis imaginar
estos superordenadores consumen una
barbaridad de energía pero no sólo eso
qué pasa si tienes cientos de
procesadores trabajando a pleno
rendimiento las 24 horas del día
efectivamente se calientan y como ya
sabéis un ordenador tiene que estar muy
bien refrigerado así que ya os podéis
imaginar lo que se gastan en aire
acondicionado todos estos centros de
minado de bitcoin dicho de otra manera
que si os queréis dedicar a minar
bitcoin ya podéis preparar la cartera
porque la factura de la luz no os va a
salir barata atentos a esta gráfica
habéis oído bien según la estimación de
la universidad de cambridge minar
bitcoin consume más energía que un país
como argentina pero esperad porque esto
no es lo peor donde están casi todos los
mineros de bitcoin pues muchos de ellos
viven en el norte de china de hecho en
ese país se estima que se mina casi el
75% del bitcoin en el mundo y os
preguntaréis por qué que tiene china
para que sea tan fantástica para el
minado de bitcoin pues principalmente
dos razones suelo barato y energía
barata y aquí es donde viene la gran
pregunta de dónde proviene casi toda la
energía en china pues sí del carbón que
como ya sabréis muchos es la energía más
contaminante y todo esto explica
noticias como este 29 de mayo de 2021 la
huella que deja bitcoin en el medio
ambiente amenaza el futuro de la divisa
entendéis ahora dónde está el problema
pues atentos porque donde surge un
problema surge una solución y aquí es
donde entra el factor islandia
[Música]
el país donde la energía es gratis
habéis oído bien en islandia la energía
es gratis o prácticamente gratis pero no
sólo eso además el 100% de la energía
que se consume en islandia es verde no
me creéis pues atentos a esta noticia
island de ofrece unas condiciones únicas
en el mundo para producir cripto monedas
por su energía geotérmica muy barata y
100% renovable ella solo que se estaría
preguntando muchos pero qué clase de
magia negra es esta que han hecho en
islandia para tener energía verde y
gratuita pues aquí viene la gran ventaja
de vivir aislado en mitad del atlántico
y es que veréis islandia está justo en
la falla que separa la placa tectónica
euroasiática de la norteamericana habéis
oído bien hay un lugar de islandia donde
puedes saltar y decir ahora estoy en
eurasia ahora estoy en norteamérica y
todo esto tiene una consecuencia
islandia es una isla volcánica con una
enorme actividad geotérmica si mis
queridos amigos de visual política
islandia es famoso por los géiseres las
aguas termales y los volcanes con
nombres impronunciables que cortan el
espacio europeo cada vez que entran en
erupción y todo esto no sólo se traduce
en el lugar perfecto para el turismo o
grabar juego de tronos también
de fuentes de energía naturales y
renovables pero no sólo eso otra cosa
que caracteriza a islandia es el frío la
temperatura media anual en este país
roza los 5 grados y esto genera un
montón de problemas pero oh sorpresa es
una enorme ventaja si quieres refrigerar
grandes servidores o grandes centros de
bitcoin en otras palabras que era
cuestión de tiempo que nos encontráramos
noticias como esta
islandia es tierra de volcanes géiseres
y ahora también bitcoins por ejemplo
génesis mining génesis mining es hoy en
día una de las mineras más importantes
de bitcoin en el mundo en el año 2016
instalaron una planta de minado de
cripto monedas que se llama enigma
minamb bitcoin hacer yum y otras criptas
durante las 24 horas del día los 365
días del año pero no son los únicos cada
vez es más frecuente que nos encontremos
con noticias como esta
a interés garden lanza una nueva granja
en islandia para la minería en la nube
de bitcoin martyrium los beneficios y la
rentabilidad de minar en este país han
sido descubiertos por diferentes
empresas que buscan su parte del pastel
pero recordáis que el mencioné en la
enorme demanda de electricidad de estos
mineros esto podría representar un
problema para islandia pues atentos a
los siguientes el uso de la energía
destinada al bitcoin en islandia
superará la de los hogares según una
empresa local así es la energía que
utilizan estas empresas en islandia se
dice que ya sobrepasa la que usan todos
los hogares del país y os preguntaréis
dónde está el problema a fin de cuentas
la energía en islandia no contamina qué
problema hay entonces no sería
fantástico si todos los mineros de
bitcoin del mundo se mudarán a islandia
pues ahora mismo vamos a ver la otra
cara de la moneda atentos
de hong kong de las cripto divisas
[Música]
puede que sorprenda pero esta no es la
primera vez que islandia tiene una
industria financiera tan potente la
última vez que este país ocupó las
portadas de los periódicos financieros
terminaron en bancarrota os contaremos
esta historia con más profundidad en uno
de los próximos vídeos que vamos a sacar
aquí en visual político la pregunta es
cómo salieron de la crisis y la
respuesta es encontrando nuevos sectores
económicos por los que apostar el
primero y el más importante es el
turismo atentos a esta gráfica
para que os hagáis una idea en el año
2014 islandia ya atrae a más de un
millón de turistas al año esto es más de
tres veces su población local desde el
año 2011 el turismo supone uno de cada
dos empleos nuevos que se crean en el
país otro sector fundamental es la pesca
y la minería de aluminio pero desde el
año 2016 hay otro sector todavía más
prometedor según la island block change
fundation el 8 por ciento de todos los
bitcoins se han minado allí usando
energía geotérmica e hidroeléctrica como
ya os hemos dicho es imposible calcular
exactamente cuánto bitcoin se mina en el
mundo hay estimaciones que dicen que el
8% del vídeo en que se mira ahora mismo
viene de islandia el gobierno ha
recibido a estas empresas con los brazos
abiertos y es lógico que lo hagan
[Música]
un informe de kpmg afirma que en 2016
antes de que la hoja actual realmente se
afianzará el sector de los centros de
datos ya había aportado cerca del 1 por
ciento al pib del país esto fue en el
año 2016 en el momento en el que hacemos
este vídeo podría ser muchísimo más y ya
sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos los
que seáis veteranos seguidores de visual
político y os imaginaréis de cuál es el
problema y los que no seáis veteranos
seguidores de visual político os podéis
suscribir a este canal y darle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones muchos
pensaréis que el problema del bitcoin en
islandia es que terminen volviéndose
dependientes de una única industria
verdad pues lo cierto es que no por el
momento- islandia sigue teniendo una
economía muy diversificada es difícil
pensar que bitcoin vaya a cambiar eso
pensarlo bien la mayor parte de las
empresas de minería de bitcoin apenas
tienen a gente contratada es decir
genera mucho dinero para el país pero la
mayoría de la gente trabaja en otros
sectores entonces dónde está el problema
pues fijaos en esta gráfica
aquí podéis ver el consumo de energía de
islandia desde el año 2006 empezó a
subir como la espuma en principio la
primera subida se explica por la minería
de aluminio el aluminio fue una de las
primeras industrias que ayudó a este
país a salir de la crisis y consume
muchísima energía sin embargo a partir
de 2016 vuelve a crecer y diréis por qué
pues porque por estas fechas es cuando
los mineros de bitcoin empezaron a
instalarse por el país es decir que con
la llegada de nuevas empresas de bitcoin
la demanda se ha disparado y está
sucediendo lo siguiente la región
nórdica al paraíso verde de bitcoin se
queda sin excedente de electricidad
habéis oído bien el aluminio más la
minería de bitcoins está poniendo contra
las cuerdas la oferta de energías verdes
que este país tiene y os preguntaréis
pero de verdad la script o divisas han
aumentado tanto la demanda de energía
pues atentos a esta gráfica aquí podéis
ver como cada año el consumo de energía
de los servidores y los datacenters
crece un 50% cada año y si los números
de bitcoin están incluidos en la
categoría de data centers
hecho de transformar que el consumo de
energía de bitcoin está a punto de
superar la producción de energía de
islandia y todo esto significa que tarde
o temprano este país tendrá que aumentar
su capacidad para generar energía así
que la pregunta es pueden producir aún
más energía verde y la respuesta es que
si no solamente pueden sacar aún más
partido de la geotermia es que además
islandia está empezando a construir
molinillos eólicos veréis hasta hace muy
pocos años islandia apenas podía
instalar energía eólica y diréis por qué
pues porque no había molinillos que
aguantarán los vendavales que por lo
visto se dan en esta isla ahora hay
tecnología que sí permite construir
parques eólicos en islandia de hecho de
otra forma el problema no es la ecología
tampoco es la falta de diversificación
así que os preguntaréis dónde demonios
está el problema
fonseca por favor deja de crear los hype
dinos lo ya pues el problema es el
siguiente qué pasaría si algún día las
cripto divisas dejarán de ser rentables
pensadlo así en estos últimos años tanto
bitcoin como cerion como muchas otras
cripto divisas han crecido a niveles
realmente sorprendentes
y esto ha servido para que un montón de
emprendedores se lancen a crear sus
centros de minado de criptas ahora
islandia tiene que construir más
generadores de energía pero y si algún
día la fiebre de las criptas se pasará
qué pasaría entonces con toda esta
energía instalada paréntesis sí ya lo sé
muchos de vosotros pensáis que las
cripto divisas han llegado aquí para
quedarse pero seamos honestos ninguno de
nosotros sabe lo que va a pasar en el
futuro y es muy razonable pensar que
aunque bitcoin siga existiendo en 20
años ya no sea tan rentable como es
ahora por supuesto cada cual tiene su
propia opinión y es muy legítima pero es
innegable que la posibilidad de que las
cripto divisas' dejen de estar tan en
boga es una posibilidad factible en este
caso que haría islandia con toda esa
inversión en generación de energía que
habrá tenido que hacer ante este
problema hay dos posibles soluciones la
primera es que islandia se plantee
exportar energía verde a otros países
es cierto que sería muy costoso porque
tendrían que extender cables submarinos
que no son precisamente baratos pero
podría convertirse en una nueva vía de
ingresos para el país la segunda opción
es que el estado no pague ninguno de
estos molinillos de bien
es decir que sean los propios mineros de
bitcoin quienes tengan que pagar sus
propias fuentes de energía esta solución
es muy interesante porque permitiría que
se instalarán todos los mineros de
visión que hicieran falta ahora bien
podría hacer que islandia dejará de ser
tan rentable para el mundo del aspecto
es más otros países nórdicos como
noruega podrían terminar siendo una
opción mejor así que ahora la pregunta
es para vosotros qué creéis que debería
hacer
islandia creéis que es bueno que el
estado islandés apueste por la script o
divisas y construya parques eólicos
pagados con dinero público o sería mejor
que todos estos parques eólicos fueran
propiedad privada de los mineros de
bitcoin dicho de otra manera que los
mineros de bitcoin gestionarán la
energía que consumen de verdad creéis
que islandia puede llegar a convertirse
en el 'wall street' de las cripto
divisas podeis dejarme vuestra respuesta
en los comentarios y como siempre no
olvidéis que aquí en visual politics
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas
así que suscribimos a este canal y darle
a la campanita para no perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto